there's some things that are just
intrinsic to buildings that make it to
where automating and connecting
everything don't work like one of the
big things is like why can't we make
buildings the way tesla makes cars right
tesla automated the heck out of making
these cars
and you know robots do all this assembly
it's absolutely beautiful they automated
the line so that you know it can make
this car today and make a different type
of car tomorrow you know like it's it's
really impressive well one of the big
reasons why we can't make buildings the
way we make cars is
cars are a mass-produced item that's
made entirely from custom parts right
like the doors for a tesla don't fit on
my subaru they don't fit on my prius
like the doors for a tesla are just for
a tesla they're all custom-made parts
for a mass-produced item right buildings
are the opposite right it's a totally
custom item that's made almost entirely
from mass-produced parts right so those
are all those pieces are just that's
just timber that you can buy from a
lumber yard those straps and stuff are
off-the-shelf items or they were just
like welded up at a shop somewhere you
know buildings are 90
just off the shelf stuff you know that's
minimally modified if modified at all
and just put together into a totally
custom one-off thing
part of that is because of this
so
buildings are a result of a lot of
different forces coming together at the
same time okay so you have cultural
things that are happening right where a
building that you know looks like a
hospital here in the bay area would not
fly in philadelphia right like
philadelphia expects a hospital to look
different
just culturally local culture is a big
issue um
there's also political issues right like
you know trying to build on the san
francisco waterfront or trying to build
in oakland or different areas there's
local codes and local government things
you have to deal with
economics impacts areas like what's
viable to build
here in california you would cost twice
as much to build somewhere else just or
take twice as much to heat you know with
a performance issue like if you build a
typical california house and you put it
in the arizona desert like they did in
phoenix now you're paying hundreds of
dollars in cooling bills every summer
because you had your giant picture
window that looked out at your swimming
pool which is a terrible idea to have in
arizona but hey you know um so every
building is this like weird combination
of hyper local issues right and so it's
almost impossible to think that we could
like crank out mass-produced buildings
that would fit because everybody would
want it customized and edited for their
specific spot
also the construction industry kind of
works at its own time scale right this
is from stuart brand's talk that was
here just a little while ago who was
here at that talk it was great
cool
so this idea of pace layers and these
layers move at different speeds right so
we're mostly in that infrastructure
layer the building industry
is the last to adopt new technology and
that's not always because they're stingy
or like because they're scared of new
technology um
uh not to call you out dylan but
architect friend of mine here how long
did you work on the stanford project
that you worked on
only about three years
but how long did the project go for it
was like
four or five years right so it when a
single think of how much technology has
changed in five years when it comes to
like these things right
there's hospital projects that are 15 20
years in the making right by the time
the project is done whatever cad system
you're using for the project won't run
on modern operating systems anymore
and yet you're contractually obliged by
the contract to deliver the cad files in
that format so you're running like
virtualized systems that are running old
os's to be able to run old cad systems
to be able to
yeah yeah it gets ugly fast um but also
really big contractors really big
builders really big developers they're
really just risk and resource managers
right the really big contractors that
are building those hospitals or building
the sky right the skyscrapers in
downtown san francisco they might not
even have a single
person on their staff that actually does
physical construction
they they're almost finance companies at
that point where they're and there's
literally like some of the larger
contractors have people working for them
that are hedge almost like hedge fund
managers that are buying steel futures
so seven years from now when you buy the
steel to build your hospital it's hedged
in case steel doubles in price in that
seven years right
so they're very risk averse so unless
they know that a technology is going to
work they don't really go into it but
then also
weirdly enough part of the building
industry works at that top layer too
right where there's last minute changes
for variety of reasons
planning around certain things can be
really difficult like hospital projects
have to most hospital projects because
they take five to seven years to build
by the time the project is done the mri
machines that they plan to have in the
hospital are totally outdated now so
they purposely plan to be able to just
okay in seven years from now when they
actually buy the real machine it has to
fit in the room that we designed seven
years ago
you know so there's all this crazy stuff
that happens so the time scale too is
something that lends itself to where
it's very difficult for us to mass
produce buildings you know in the way
that we build cars
[Music]